can we fly through can we play
ow it was your fault
you did this oh
she just disappeared
what the he didn't see anything he
didn't see anything cover up the
evidence
cover up the evidence oh god what do i
do decoy
oh what a cat's still there huh i'm just
gonna be right back the bunkie
i'm gonna be our bag i tried oh there's
another cat i hear another cat
hey kitty kitty kitty kitty hey kitty
kitty kitty kitty
i hear him hey i have a kitty i have
kitty snacky
where are you where is this little snake
is kitty in the walls
oh there you are hey hey
[Music]
oh god there's no floor
hey kitty kitty
[Music]
make it eat
oh my god oh hey little one
why are they so annoying love me
you will love me you will love me
you will love me
oh my god jesus christ the acrobatics on
this thing
come back here i have other stuff
planned for this episode i don't have
time for this
oh i got him how much fish do you need
did i get him
i fed him eight fishes love me
there you go all right
[Music]
i'm actually not wearing the baby now i
gotta be careful with the light right
hold up
bonkey still doesn't suspects the thing
don't worry bunky
uh bad for water we're changing the bath
water today it's our bath water change
fest
festival all right so now we just gotta
fly up
[Music]
why aren't you flying why aren't you
flying
at least go in the water then
oh my god they're so annoying i hate
cats i hate cats all right i'll figure
this out in a minute
let me show you some really sick stuff
i've done
with my build i improved the furnace and
it's now what i like to call it
giga furnace giga furnace
gigafernet gigaferno
it's an infinite automatic smart
auto sorting auto disposing automatic
smelter no
i heard another what are you doing here
this is dangerous down there
got me you want to see how it's done
okay finally someone is interested
i don't know why anytime i show any one
of my friends
my automatic self-sorting self-disposing
infinite automatic smelter people just
don't care
and i'm just like but it's really cool
trust me you'll you'll be amazed alright
let's say
an hypothetical right
[Music]
oh you're following me you're following
me okay let's say in hypothetical
situation
you have a box you collected some sand
and you want to melt the sand obviously
because you want it to be glass
and then you have a bunch of other stuff
that's like oh i gotta sort out this
inventory
not with the giga about this i'm sorting
it automatic selfie for the infinite
system
and even redstone repeaters goes in the
system all you got to do is hit it on
one of these hoppers
hit the lever boom they get distributed
it's not cool isn't that cool you think
it's cool
thanks no one ever thinks it's cool i
don't get it either really
all right so just to for the sake of
showing you guys how it works
i think it's pretty cool um have i shown
down here by the way i dug at the whole
mountain oh this is all mountain i
dug it all out and put net i don't know
if i shown it but it's pretty sick
so all the items comes through the
central hub right
but the items that i want to smelt you
guys already know this
uh that are sand will go through here
and i also want to smell the ancient
debris gold
iron um sponge so
it automatically detects it here before
it actually goes into the system
it's really cool guys before it goes and
you hit them it goes here
no big deal all right sure we've seen
that before but the cool part about it
is that it goes into this
chest that then gets collected by these
hoppers
that then distributes it to these
furnaces underneath
which is still okay whatever we've seen
that before
but i made this cool system here where i
noticed they don't collect enough
uh they would just bounce back and forth
kind of like this one does
and it wouldn't collect enough material
so i built this yeah i know it's cool
right
it's cool yeah uh so i built this little
thing
that sends a signal with the activator
rail
there it goes signal goes click click
click and then it sends it off
so it actually stays underneath the the
chest
for a long enough time for it to really
fill up
it's a small thing but it really changes
it a lot
and it makes it way better way better
and it works out really well let's see
how much they collect actually hey we
got more sand coming in
well i suppose i can check the chest
itself right
all right it's got a bunch of sand in it
chess comes in boom gets them all i saw
one guy
it's so cool seeing what the minecraft
the community or whatever he's doing
i saw one guy build it with a comparator
so he would know if they were
actually full and unless it was
completely full then it would go which
is
it's really cool but i don't need that
because the mine is not that big
i am limited by the time of these so
there's no reason for me to go
overboard with it it's also infinite
fuel you i used to have it so cold comes
in
i'm way too excited about talking about
this is ridiculous but i think it's cool
i spent a lot of time on it
what happened to me what happened to me
i in these these are all drains to a
different
bamboo farm which i've set up here and
why
is are they not working you should yeah
you see them coming in here
and they are used on each side yeah we
got more coming in here
they're always working they're very
efficient but bamboo is not a great
source of fuel but
as we know if you build enough for them
it doesn't matter so all of these are
oh jesus are constantly being
distributed into all the furnaces
uh you see the hopper is full there we
go so it's always melting
then once the glass is melted through
this uh
i have another dropper here it spits it
out
it goes back into this bad boy which is
one of my main pumps
follow me kitty we're going through the
elevator
it's a bit loud but hey uh goes through
the main pump which then
goes from here
back there into the system
shoots it back through and then it goes
back
here baby as you can see it's filling up
like crazy fast i think it already
yeah we got one winner wow
wow that's so cool felix
i know i know it's whatever another one
okay i don't think i had enough
materials i think that it's running low
it's whatever that's whatever it's
really good it's
it's really good look it's empty all
right i've already done the job
and that's it that's the the giga giga
furnish
gig up burn it oh oh oh
i somehow have not lit this up properly
and i don't know why giga furnace
oh oh it's pretty cool i like it
it's fun to see how hard i can push this
automatic
system that i built it's kind of
ridiculous but this is a nice addition
to the model
module thank you i have all my jesus
christ they're loud
i have all my farms here so here are my
bamboo there's actually one underneath
as well
dude it looks so sick with the smoke uh
here is my chicken farm
which we will actually use today uh it
collects eggs here's my paper farm
here is my sheep farm there up there is
my netherite farm
up there is my melon and my pumpkin farm
and up here
are my regular farms and then i made it
nice and cool i finally did it
uh for all the uh villagers as well
isn't that cool isn't that cool kitty
you're my new companion
you follow me now i actually prefer you
here you're not bath water evil
we're still missing all the villagers i
don't really need them anymore i mean i
got all this
right but yeah let's go back up so one
thing that i wanted to do
is like the base looks really sick right
we have all these
uh beacons and i thought it could be
really cool to have like a
blood moon or something how something
like right above it
isn't that would that be cool right
kitty like something evil
like hovering above it maybe something
in lava maybe something in like
i'm stuck in the water are you kidding
me guess i turn into bathwater kitty now
huh
i've been playing all week in case
you're wondering it's ridiculous
this game has consumed me i i need
another hobby i need to get back to
working on music or some productive
this is ridiculous uh but yeah here's
the
i want to do a giga beacon i only got
three so far
i think you can do six and i have uh
enough for one more uh oh i've been
collecting these as well
i don't know what to do with them i
thought you could use them for farms
but that's what we're gonna do today
we're gonna get some more of this
through my egg farm
we're gonna kill the wither with eggs
that's right no one's ever done this
not really but hey we're we're gonna try
all right off to the nether
bruh look at all the buffs i'm gonna
have all six of them
it's gonna be sick follow me kitty don't
follow me
alright so we're off kitty no
kitty go home
go home kitty go home
this is dangerous kitty go home go
home stop following me you could die
a death oh all right here listen
what was that kitty please
if anything happened to you i don't know
what i do it
all right so we're going to the end
because apparently this no i forgot i
forgot
i forgot we got to go back always forget
the soul sand somehow i don't know how
someone told me you can put carpet on
these i've been doing it but not
everywhere so
just to stop the spawns kitties
go home bro what's wrong with cats in
this game i never use the cat as a pet
shoosh
oh now i have to kill it no you can be a
guardian
yeah you stay see how long the chicken
will last in the nether you know
all right now we go to the end kitty
no don't follow me to the end to the end
to the end to the end
okay good we lost we lost him
we gucci my game what's brewing my game
got that enchanted all right so
here's what i've been doing
this is apparently how people do the
wither
without any sort of problem it really
feels like cheating and i
i set up this thing even too we're gonna
dispose all the eggs
and try and get as many of these eggs
out as quick as we can
yeah shoot me ah
i shoot back
do it do it oh yeah oh yeah
so the way the weather works is that any
animal that the wither kills
it will then turn into a wither oh so
this is basically how you farm withers
with the roses by then poisoning them
because it doesn't kill them it just
puts them at the lowest uh
health i'm sorry chickens i'm sorry that
you are so weak that you have to die
ow ow ow
okay i'm sorry then what you do is you
put the wither here all right here we go
let me out let me out let me out let me
out let me out
sorry chickens sorry
dude look at the damage
[Music]
it's ridiculous all right
look at the damage i do on this
bye ah not many of you died i should
have used more poison
and that's how it's done baby sorry you
were all supposed to die so i'm just
gonna
i'm just kidding i don't have to do that
yeah
boy so there you go easy nether star
that's apparently how people do it the
easy way get them
get out of my get in my
get how are you lying oh my god you get
to limb
if you survive this shot ah that's too
bad he was close
apparently you can build an uh enderman
form as well which seems pretty cool but
it seems dangerous and i'm too scared
but uh
yeah you can hear them underneath that's
ridiculous
you have no home bed oh my god why is he
stuck
dude waddles your design sucks i haven't
changed it and they still get stuck
hey bro you need to push
why aren't you going down i'm wearing
the eli track
jesus christ what a difference all right
there we go burning helm
god damn boy
all right oh can i make it out of line
oh yeah perfect
oh another one bites the dust it's so
satisfying
watching them burn is that what does
that say about me
[Music]
thank you thank you back in the system
oh it's night time that's perfect i
actually have another thing to show you
guys it's really cool
uh it's very simple but it's really fun
here i have
creeper disc farm let me definitely
change armor
so we just have to find a creeper and
not die in the process
there we go here's one hey creeper hey
creeper cryptographer
hey little creeper come on follow me
trust me it's going to be awesome this
way this way
oh you're going to get me oh no he got
trapped oh he feels so stupid
oh no he's going to die no jigsaw scared
me
bro just die bro
oh no he did and uh yeah for those of
you probably know this but
if a skeleton archer kills a creeper
they always drop music disc which is
really cool
we got chirp i don't have that another
one to the collection
it's small stuff like this that's really
fun i don't know
oh don't blow it gosh dave's gonna die
sorry creeper i didn't mean to kill you
oh he lives excellent follow me
oh no you're gonna get me oh they're
they're faces of disappointment every
time
it's too good
oh another one a purple one maul okay
i'll take them all one shot
follow me little creeper he's so excited
he's like finally
oh what the hell is this another disc
13 i have that dang it one more one more
come on
you got it creeper come to papi
oh no oh
poor creeper this is my revenge or the
pain they cost me
all right what do we get no
uh which cd ward all right let's let's
go and check them out
dude once once the blood moon has
arrived the fire nation will be more
powerful than you can ever believe
it's going to be epic once the blood
moon is going to find 55 we didn't
find anything wait i forgot to put the
beacon oh my god i'm getting so ahead of
myself
first let's put on some music while we
shall we
how about sure that sounds good right
[Music]
okay all right
hey hey hey let's go
this thing slaps let me just put my
stuff
uh with so much pro uh it's so annoying
having to sort out all my inventory
which i don't have to do
well thank you guys for another epic
video
i love minecraft
oh oh it took a different turn
and i hope to keep delivering these
videos to you even though i beat the
game and it's getting ridiculous
once all the beacons are complete
then will i truly be in the game
another one oh
it changes i like it
all right on this one we will add
string
this is pewdiepie minecraft veteran
veteran
signing off see you next one
[Music]